Let's try the four one seven area code next.
Who's calling today from four one seven
Hey, dev is Tyler.
Hey Tyler, what's up?
Okay,
so this is the 75th anniversary of FTRs 1944
address to Congress on where he introduced
the second bill of rights and economic bill
of rights already of course, and June.
He called for a 21st century economic bill
of rights.
What do you think about the value of having
an actual declaration of economic rights that
could be committed to by representatives,
citizens, organizations as a unifying expression
of what the democratic party and Democrats
are supposed to stand for?
It would be delightful, but it would also
be the type of thing that very rarely actually
makes change happen.
So that's my only hesitation.
I mean, I love all that stuff.
It's great to put pen to paper and say, this
is what we're for and this is what we believe
in.
But at the same time it, you know, show me
exactly how it'll make change happen and I
don't know if it will.
What do you think would be the challenges
in terms of something like that actually making
a difference for us?
Of course, we have many of these pledges throughout
history.
Recently, the sunrise movements with their
no fossil fuel money pledge seems to be having
an impact.
Some pledges have an impact, many of them
have absolutely no impact.
Yeah.
Idea of tried to have something.
That's serves as a straightforward litmus
test.
The democratic party in my mind and no way
has resembled FDRs party and no way resembles
and Nordic model as social democratic party.
Right.
And so, so what, you know, what would be the
challenges?
Something like this.
Well listen, in the end, the declaration needs
to come with controlling the white house,
the house of representatives in the Senate.
I mean that's how you're going to get change.
You, you take control, you outline your values
and priorities and then you make it happen
and you know, it's like the, the sad reality
is if the Senate is controlled by Republicans
and Democrats sign on and say, this is our
vision.
Okay, who cares?
And it's like, I'm not being cynical, I'm
just trying to be a realist here and this
is not me saying, Oh, it's stupid.
Online petition culture.
Petitions don't matter.
I'm not saying that in any way.
I'm just saying there are elements of the
system that we know how it is that you change
them and we've got to control the white house,
the house of representatives in the Senate
in order to make it happen.
Right.
That makes sense.
Not to mention that not all, not all democratic.
It's important.
Also, not all Democrats in the house and Senate
are on the same page on every issue.
And that's another obstacle.
Yeah.
I mean, that's why I think it would be an
upfront litmus test.
You know, like maybe a way of creating great
oppression.
I mean, it's great that Bernie Sanders comes
out with a call for a 21st century bill of
rights, but he's one candidate and it's one
platform, right?
That's not inviting the American people.
It's not inviting other candidates, other
representatives, Tucson on board.
So that was the thought that maybe this would
be a means of getting a lot more pressure
on democratic candidates or incumbents to
actually commit to a common expression of
what their party is supposed to be about.
Yeah.
I mean, I, I don't disagree, but besides the
practical problem, there's also like, then
you get people who want to put in stuff that's
a little bit loony and then it's like, then
people stay stray away from it and it just
becomes its own problem too.
But it's an interesting idea.
I appreciate the call.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right, take care.